or nous sommes le mardi 15 mars merci de
nous retrouver pour cette nouvelle
édition du 7 8 le journal votre
actualité locale
chaque jour entourés de nos invités mais
également des journalistes de la
rédaction tout de suite lé titre de
cette édition
l'élection du nouveau président de l'ue
vs qui aura lieu le 24 mars prochain
jean luc vestiaires président sortant
est également candidat à un nouveau
mandat
il est notre invité ce soir nous
reviendrons avec lui également sur la
première cérémonie de remise de diplômes
de l'université et les opposants à la
vente du domaine de thiverval grignon ne
décolère pas ce week-end il était à
nouveau mobilisés contre le projet de
vente du site a notamment au paris saint
germain et antoine grêlé à 25 ans il
habite viroflay il a été élu président
des jeunes démocrates une association
qui rassemble les jeunes adhérents
centriste de 16 à 32 ans depuis 2007
focus sur ce jeune chinois dans notre
chronique politique et contrôle routier
aujourd'hui sur la route nationale 186
vers saint germain en laye sous
réquisition du procureur de la
république
les policiers ont procédé à des
contrôles de véhicules ouverture de
coffre est permis de conduire un
contrôle routier particulier puisque la
direction départementale des services de
police du 78 étaient assistés d'une
délégation indienne composée de onze
responsables commissariats locaux une
opération destinée à présenter le
travail des agents français concernant
notamment la sécurité routière écouter
aujourd'hui on fait un contrôle routier
relativement classique avec toutes les
réquisitions du procureur public de
versailles qui nous autorise notamment à
ouvrir les coffres à contrôler
l'identité de toute personne circulant
sur le territoire sur le secteur en tous
les cas et nous faisons ça au profit
d'une délégation de policiers indiens
qui vient voir en france comment on
traite le problème de l'insécurité
routière
chez nous la police travaille sur les
mêmes situations que nous avons les
mêmes problèmes
mais c'est le contexte qui est différent
ce que nous
comprendre ici c'est comment la
technologie utilisée en france pourrait
être utilisé chez nous en inde
nous avons plusieurs situations et nous
avons pu voir en application ces
équipements je suis certain que cela
sera utile pour nos équipes en inde de
réfléchir comment utiliser ces
équipements la chesnoye et passons à
présent notre entretien l'élection du
nouveau président de l'université de
versailles saint-quentin-en-yvelines
approche il ya trois listes connues deux
candidats se présentent à cette élection
didier guillemot enseignants chercheurs
et médecins que nous avions reçues en
plateau le 24 février dernier et
jean-luc vaissière actuel président de
l'université depuis bientôt quatre ans
où on saura vous bonsoir merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation
alors tout d'abord pourquoi vous
représenter à cette élection qu'elle est
un peu votre projet l'idée de consignes
et justement votre projet voilà une
petite précision je suis également selon
un chercheur n'est pas médecin pourquoi
je me représente pourquoi sujet des
valeurs des principes qui m'ont un non
sens doivent régir universités
françaises et diverses et
saint-quentin-en-yvelines 2 je souhaite
me battre pour ces principes
d'autre part j'ai l'ambition pour cette
université
une ambition de développement de
rayonnement d'aller au delà de ce
qu'elle est aujourd'hui et je pense que
j'ai l'expérience la connaissance des
réseaux pour aider à cette ambition
en quelques mots sacrés rappelé
difficile à terme un tel bilan
faites-vous justement de ces quatre
années qui sont passés et vidéo est
alors j'ai failli à différents 60 voire
le bihan et eu des beaux des hauts et
des bas mais au bilan aujourd'hui on a
une université pour lesquels les
fondamentaux étaient rétablis en termes
financiers anoblé bilan 2015 c'est un
résultat positif de 5 millions d'euros
sur 130 millions c'est donc des marges
de manoeuvre pour lancer de nouveaux
projets donc pas un ordre 2016 en à une
campagne de recrutement d'enseignants de
personnes amis sportifs normal on met un
des financements spécifiques pour
l'innovation pédagogique
donc voilà donc on arta financier un bon
bilan
par ailleurs l'université ne s'est pas
endormi pendant quatre ans ce serait
faire insulte aux collègues qui sont
toujours bouillonnant d'idées et de
projets puisque pour mémoire on a ouvert
youpi l'astucieux politique de sagem en
lien avec nos collègues de cergy
pontoise en septembre 2014
pour mémoire on a aussi ouvert l'école
supérieure du professeur à et
l'éducation sur l'académie avec les aux
universités de l'académie pour mémoire
on a développé l'institut la transition
énergétique le véhicule décarboné
communiquant les décors pour lequel
d'ailleurs il ya un événement jeudi
pour mémoire on a explosé le montant des
contrats que nous avons avec les
entreprises avec l'europe en termes de
recherche dans cette université qui a
plein de projets je viens de recevoir
cet après midi un message du cnrs pour
dire qu'on avait nouvelle un nouveau
partenariat avec le cnrs sur des
questions de patrimoine
cette année on fête a également les 25
ans et sql cette occasion il ya beaucoup
de nouveautés notamment grâce samedi les
étudiants qui ont obtenu leur master en
2015 ont assisté à la première cérémonie
de remise de diplômes organisée par
l'université de versailles saint quentin
en yvelines
une cérémonie à l'américaine que vous
allez le voir tout de suite attention
j'entends la 3
un show digne des plus grandes
universités américaines à la faculté de
saint quentin en yvelines samedi 12 mars
quelques 1800 étudiants ayant validé
leur master l'année dernière ont
participé à cette première cérémonie des
remises de diplômes chapeau toge et
écharpe était de mise
on sait qu'on va la mettre une fois
après on voit là on va la garder en tant
qu' en tant que souvenir
ça avait quelque chose de particulier
j'ai trouvé très intéressant fait que
c'est à dire mesdames et diplomatie
officielle qui est important parce que
ça permettent d'acter la paix qu'on soit
diplômé et cette reconnaissance de la
part de tout des professeurs et puis
dire voilà aussi on some diplômés
enseignants élus responsables de
formation famille
près de 3000 personnes étaient réunies
pour assister à cet événement il ya une
certaine portée symbolique qui quitte un
peu le monde du cocooning de
l'université le monde de l'enfance pour
passer dans le monde des adultes
responsables
l'enjeu est avant tout de montrer la
qualité des formations et de la
recherche de l'ue vs q c'est important
de pouvoir à l'occasion des 25 ans
l'université rassembler dans un lieu un
peu magique donc l'ensemble de
l'université
c'est ici important par rapport à
l'ancrage universités dans n'était pas
sage et démonstration de force de
qualité vingt mille étudiants sont
inscrits dans les 200 formations de
l'université
les 80 masters de l'uvs et excuse son
parti pour la grande majorité de l'offre
de formation de l'université paris
saclay dont elle est membre fondateur
alors j'en ai fait si on le voit dans le
reportage vous dit que le but est
d'affirmer sans qu'une démonstration
force de votre image par rapport à paris
saclay c'est bien ça c'était un jeu
enfin entre a trait d'humour
pas pour moi c'était important parce que
l'habitude des cérémonies de remise de
diplômes à la faculté 3 vous avez vu
cela me donne rien monique laval à l'iut
de vélizy astuces pour le management un
événement aussi festif et puis absolue
mais là c'est une autre dimension encore
plus dans le vélodrome on voyait ce que
tu universités y avait mille quelques
mille diplômés sur les 1800 les parents
les partenaires des entreprises avaient
j'ai aperçu des acteurs du technocentre
lavez les élus du territoire le député
dont il y avait quelque chose où la
musique que du décorum des chapeaux etc
qui est heureux je pense que c'est
important de voir voilà university tout
ça c'est une cérémonie un petit peu à
l'américaine l'objectif c'était c'était
de montrer un petit peu voilà que
l'inertie de versailles 50 ans lina
peut-être une portée internationale sera
le ministre a dit au micro labarde et
justement pour rats
et voilà l'objectif vous c'est paris
saclay 7 se rapprocher ce grand pôle
universitaire ces salons je les laisse
pas se rapprocher puisqu'on menait
donnant donc j'ai oublié dans mon bilan
précédemment au bilan je compte
positivement c'est à dire que maintenant
nous avons toutes les écoles doctorales
formation doctorale qui sont mutualisés
sur sacrés depuis la rentrée depuis
septembre 2001 la même manière il ya 80%
des masters qui sont mutualisés sur
paris ça crée donc on est au coeur de sa
clé on est parmi 18 fondateur de saclay
comme plus techniques comme par la suite
comme le cnrs donc maintenant il faut
avancer faire avancer le projet paraît
saclay avancer nos vies comme on dit
mais nos billets sont bien présentes
déjà on a les masters les écoles
doctorales
on a appliqué des programmes de
recherche on a vu madame le doyen de la
fac de droit pied responsable de la fac
de droit 2 par isaac et des collègues
qui sont responsable du département de
recherche 3 humaines et sociales
université déjà très présente peut
toujours faire mieux on peut toujours
faire mieux passer ce qu'on est nous
mais voilà vous dites d'ailleurs dans
votre site internet spécialement dédié à
cette campagne vestiaires 2016 point fr
par ap vous voulez proposer de nouveaux
et de nouvelles choses et puiser de
nouvelles ressources pour paris saclay
donc le but est quand même de
s'impliquer encore plus et de faire un
beau jeu les ressources vous pensez à
quoi notamment pour voilà développer des
nouvelles choses pour aller ils
devraient déjà
donc comme je le disais à ce midi lors
d'un petit réunion de campagne on va
dire donc on a déjà pu bénéficier de
millions d'euros via sa clé puisque sa
crise c'est la possibilité de faire des
patrouilles à de nouveaux partenariats
des synergies avec les collègues disent
aux établissements mais c'est également
pouvoir bénéficier de soutiens
financiers à travers l'europe est unie
saria général aux investissements les
idex et tous à nos fils finance des
projets de recherche des bourses de
mobilité des étudiants des travaux
pratiques innovant de la maturation près
maturation c'est-à-dire pour faire de
l'innovation des brevets des start up et
on arrive à nous à émarger à ces
différents sujets et ce pour ces
différents sujets vous voyez tous
voulaient trouve également des d'autres
partenaires économiques
mais le surnom est toujours bon
caractère is khan comme jeudi une
université à fort ancrage territorial
on est quand même sur un territoire
assez riche en termes d'activité
économique si je parle de vélizy ou
ou de 50 ha même si on peut pas résumer
les yvelines à série à cette série toi
rentre grandes entreprises mais on a
déjà beaucoup de partenariats en termes
de recherche que j'évoquais tout à
l'heure des contrats de recherche
que ce soit avec valeo avec traîneaux ou
d'autres acteurs économiques ont
également tout ce qui le volet formation
c'est-à-dire à travers l'apprentissage
la formation continue la situation
financière donc de l'unesco avait fait
beaucoup de bruit dans quelques années
levesque est au bord de la faillite on
sait aujourd'hui la station est revenu à
l'équilibré
que faut-il faire pour éviter une telle
situation alors que justement les
dotations baisse mais il faut être
vigilant je pense que on a beaucoup
après parce qu'il ya une période de
transition comme on ne remplit l
autonomie les rues ou l'ipad et outils
les compétences l'habitude de jeu de se
gérer
c'est se faire à parler à ce que disait
ça donne qu avait tout à l'heure les
étudiants qui deviennent grands et titre
maman à tout ça donc nous enfin à
quitter le giron de l'état c'était un
peu difficile et puis on n'a pas
forcément été bien accompagné et donc je
crois que maintenant on a appris à gérer
à être vigilants anticiper c'est ça la
question de faire des prévisions
donc là on a depuis deux ans trois ans
réussit à faire des budgets
prévisionnels sincère qu'on était
capable de tenir et voire même après a
dégagé des résultats positifs
donc après le successeur l'équipe qui va
succéder il faut que simplement qu'elles
soient sérieuses nous avions a reçu donc
votre adversaire si on peut le dire
ainsi dans cette élection et didier
guillemot chercheurs et médecins nous
l'avenir aussi en bateau le 24 février
dernier
il évoque la différence entre vos deux
projets je vous propose de l'écouter de
réagir après qu'est ce qui diffère entre
vos deux projets celui des nécessaires
et loire j'irai cas de vision il ya
probablement une vision un peu du passé
de l'université je ne prendrai qu'un
seul exemple la manière dont les
étudiants participent à la vie de
l'université
pour ce qui me concerne je considère que
l'université est une communauté
d'enseignants d'enseignants chercheurs
de personnels biatoss le mot est pas
beau et d'étudiants qui concourent
savoir qui le construisent des étudiants
font partie de l'université en sont les
acteurs
ce ne sont pas des élèves sont ne sont
pas plus des lycéens
il faut que cette communauté vivent
ensemble et construit déconstruit de
savoir en commun 4 réactions gens les
glissières quand vous entendez ça moi
j'ai pas envie de réagir parce que les
étudiants puis qu'on reconstruise de
savoir avec nous au bout d'un moment oui
quand ils sont en thèse louis causse au
masters 1000 en licence faut qu'on leur
apprennent à construire le savoir à
maîtriser les savoirs et ensuite au
travail avec eux mais je vois pas l je
vois pas trop en quoi c'est là des
licols nouvelle école sur ce point-là
particulier le jeu voilà rien d'autre à
dire et comment vous allez intégrer
justement à les étudiants à votre projet
c'est également votre volonté maintenez
les étudiants c'est au coeur de notre
activité de notre utilité sociale
gérance à la gestion de notre métier
c'est quoi c'est la formation et la
recherche la recherche nourrit la
formation notre john notre existence
en premier lieu c'est de formaliser
clients former des compétences rêverait
de les écouter plus par rapport à leur
demande de faire mieux oui moi je suis
toujours après drôle il faut aussi
qu'ils soient là pour s'exprimer mais je
pense que il n'y a pas de problèmes
d'expression des coups tu me semble
utile mais je peux me tromper
donc quand on est enfermé président
d'euros on n'était pas prêt de la
réalité me semble que à travers les
conseils où sont présents des étudiants
plus ou moins présent on peut les
entendre les écouter et quand je dis les
écouter c'est à dire prendre en compte
ce qu'ils disent aussi il a dit c'est
pas univoque c'est à dire que c'est pas
les professeurs le président qui ont le
savoir la connaissance et qui impose aux
étudiants ça passe pas ça se passe pas
comme ça dans une université
peut-être dans une école mais pas à
l'université puisque les étudiants je me
rappelle participer à l'élection du
président donc c'est quand même original
donc quelque part c'est bien
forcément ça applique un dialogue
constructif
justement les étudiants ceux qui
demandent plus globalement faire en
france parce que c'est moi qui ai vu
venir cette saint-quentin-en-yvelines
c'est la formation professionnelle
l'alternance c'est une priorité c'est
quelque chose que vous allez faire voilà
vous à les amplifier un universitaire 60
ans
amplifiée oui toujours de toujours il
ferait admet avoir mon mémoire dernier
classement 2013
je suis pas sûr qu'il serait très des
genres on est la troisième université
française en scène de pourcentage
d'étudiants en apprentissage ce qui est
remarquable de préciser si j'ai deux
secondes c'est que les quatre premières
universités françaises qu'on a produit
ce sont les quatre universités qui vont
avoir 25 ans villes de france c'est à
dire dans l'or c'est ma la vallée evry
louer cergy pontoise où les inerties
qu'ont dû avorter si je puis dire des
modèles alternatifs du développement
dont l'apprentissage et donc si on peut
encore s'il ya eu quelques
intra-africaines au développement leur
procès d'âge
on peut peut-être je peux comprendre que
les choses pouvaient changer au niveau
de la région mais il ya eu quelques
freins qui ont été mis au développement
de l'apprentissage qu'il serait bon de
lever pour partie pour nous permettre
d'aller plus loin parce que
effectivement moi je crois beaucoup à
l'apprentissage haut niveau une même de
l'université même au niveau master je
crois que c'est quelque chose de deux
lacs désavantage pour pour l'université
pour l'étudiant pour notre président une
dernière question avant de terminer cet
entretien du véhicule est entré il ya
cinq ans au classement de shanghai dont
des 500 meilleures tables sont mondiaux
supérieur de recherche est ce qu'il est
possible avec des budgets limités vu
qu'on sait que c'est le cas à présent de
conserver cette ambition au niveau de la
recherche et à l'ambition nouveau la
recherche on a toujours après sur
certains secteurs on est mieux ça parce
que juste pour mémoire on était je crois
la pro connais on dit rester deux heures
dans le classement de shanghai la
première année on y crie 499e et la
deuxième année sa 100e et puis après on
est maintenant on est peut-être 502 60
mois donc voilà donc je ne sais pas
assez bien symboliquement mais moi je
compte beaucoup sur sur l'université
paris saclay pour être beaucoup mieux
casser parce que normalement je pense
que si on arrive à bien bien jouer notre
coup au doigt et dans les vingt premiers
donc c'est mieux que cinq centièmes
merci beaucoup jean-luc baissière d'être
venu en papier d'avoir répondu à nos
questions
tout autre sujet à présent les opposants
à la vente du domaine de thiverval
grignon n'abdique pas ce week-end ils se
sont à nouveau réunis samedi matin pour
une marche de protestataires association
professeurs étudiants et politiques
s'étaient donné rendez vous près de
l'entrée de l'école de grignon un
reportage signé mélanie poquet et
patrick jacques de dixmude
le psg ou un établissement privé ils ne
veulent toujours pas en entendre parler
les opposants se sont à nouveau
rassemblés pour protéger les 490
hectares de terres agricoles de l'école
d'ingénieurs agro paris tech au bénéfice
de tous donc que ça reste public
sauvegarder ce patrimoine ce lieu qui
est qui rempli d'histoire et nous même
en tant que première année on on voit
tout ce qu'il ya derrière on voit qu'il
ya du potentiel et que
la vente au privé entraînerait la perte
de tout ça on va interpeller dans les
prochains jours le ministre de
l'agriculture puisqu'on est là face à
des questions liées à l'agriculture et
on va demander à ce qu'on ait des
garanties que maintenant qu'ils ont
décidé quand on travaille tout déménager
le site que la qualité des terres
agricoles et la biodiversité préservée
et pourquoi ne pas reconvertir ce site
en site agricole
le déménagement a été décidée en mars
2015 1200 agents seront déplacés dans
400 présents sur le site actuel de
grignon les opposants franchissent une
nouvelle étape après un collectif
composé de 180 une personne il ans une
association c'est une deuxième étape
importante dans la mesure où ça va nous
permettre de comme on dit les juristes
d'ester en justice et on a va voir un
des meilleurs avocats de france là
dessus qu'ils acceptent
exceptionnellement de prendre une
association comme clients et alors qu'il
ne fait pas d'habitude louis pense que
c'est une cause importante
cette seconde manifestation a rassemblé
plus de 200 personnes
une pétition destinée à stéphane le foll
le ministre de l'agriculture atteint
aujourd'hui plus de vingt mille
signatures et politiques à présent comme
chaque mardi wilfried est riche il nous
a rejoint pour sa chronique charles
frémont soir flore années aujourd'hui il
est question du modem plus
particulièrement des jeunes démocrates
une association qui rassemble les jeunes
adhérents centriste de 16 à 32 ans et ce
depuis 2007
les jeunes démocrates qui viennent de se
doter d'un nouveau président au niveau
national il a 25 ans il est yvelinois
originaire de viroflay il s'appelle
antonin grêlé vous allez le voir à
l'image justement dans les bureaux des
jeunes démocrates département il a fait
des études de commerce à licence il l'a
passé en angleterre il est aujourd'hui
consultant en innovation digital ça
c'est pour son parcours professionnel
pour son parcours politique c'est lui
qui nous en parle on l'écouté ya quatre
ans c'était les élections
présidentielles 2012
je m'étais rapproché de la fédération
des yvelines justement pour faire
campagne
j'ai rencontré des gens qui m'ont
vraiment donné envie de m'engager en
politique j'ai enchaîné avec la campagne
législative où j'ai soutenu le candidat
modem
localement j'ai rencontré des citoyens
qui étaient engagés dans la politique de
leur commune et par la suite je me suis
présenté aux élections municipales dont
je suis conseiller municipal depuis 2013
et ce mandat aux jeunes démocrates au
niveau national va courir sur deux ans
il va donc devoir s'impliquer dans la
campagne de la présidentielle et ensuite
des législatives
ce qu'attendent aujourd'hui elle et les
jeunes en particulier
c'est des propositions qui sortent un
peu du lot il faut qu'on arrête un petit
peu le recyclage des idées j'ai
l'impression qu'aujourd'hui les partis
de gauche de droite de gauche sont
bloqués ont du mal à créer de nouvelles
choses à inventer des nouvelles idées
même allait s'inspirer de ce qui se
passe autour de nous en europe là où ça
fonctionne on a des énormes difficultés
aujourd'hui on a la priorité du chômage
on a une éducation qui a besoin
d'évoluer et on n'a pas vraiment de
propositions ni à gauche ni à droite
pour vraiment faire avancer ça et je
crois que notre rôle en tant
qu'organisation aux jeunes et en tant
qu'organisation centriste c'est
justement de jouer l'innovation
l'invention et de proposer des nouvelles
idées pour faire bouger ce monde
politique a tellement besoin d'énergie
de dynamique
les jeunes démocrates qui entendent
faire du centre un incubateur d'idées
c'est ce qui ressort du discours de ce
nouveau président néanmoins il ne faut
pas oublier qu'aujourd'hui le modem a
clairement fait le choix de s'associer à
la droite
si le modem a obtenu des sièges dans les
communes dans les départements dans les
régions c'est en partant pendant la
campagne aux côtés des républicains est
difficile donc d'exister à part entière
dans ces conditions même si françois
bayrou président du modem n'a pas dit
son dernier mot si je considère que
c'est mon devoir je ne me déroberai pas
ce sont ses mots
en clair s'ils sont favoris alain juppé
ne remporte pas la primaire à droite il
se présentera pour en revenir à antonin
grêlé à ces jeunes démocrates nous lui
avons posé une dernière question car les
jeunes on les voit souvent en ce moment
dans les rues
une partie d'entre eux est très en
colère contre la future loi travail
à tort ou à raison de sa réponse je
pense que les jeunes ont le sentiment de
ne pas être entendu qu'on ne s'occupe
pas suffisamment d'heures préoccupation
je pense qu'ils sont profondément
inquiets le chômage des jeunes
aujourd'hui c'est 25% et et dans ce
genre de situation on peut on peut que
comprendre le
la colère et la peur surtout
l'inquiétude de ne pas trouver demain un
poste un travail qui correspond aux
études qu'on a souhaité faire je crois
profondément que cette réforme est
nécessaire
pas forcément ces propositions là mais
on a besoin de changer le code du
travail
on a un vrai problème avec 70 % des
créateurs d'entreprises qui ont peur de
recruter on peut pas à maintenir notre
notre pays dans la peur et il pourrait
t'il contre cette réforme visiblement il
est plutôt pour est il favorable ou
opposé à la mobilisation des jeunes
visiblement il est favorable en tout cas
il comprend cette mobilisation le
président des jeunes démocrates vous
l'avez entendu qui ne veut brusquer
personne ni oui ni non antonin grêlé
serait donc bien un centriste convaincu
merci wilfried et passons à tout autre
sujet à présent dans le cadre de la
semaine de l'artisanat ne vous proposons
cette semaine une série de reportages
hier nous vous avions présenté le métier
de souffleur de verre aujourd'hui
deuxième épisode c'est au tour
d'isabelle cadeau de nous parler de sa
passion elle est peintre sur porcelaine
depuis une trentaine d'années nous
sommes allés l'a rencontré dans son
atelier aux loges en josas un portrait
signé camille lambert et des porcelaines
qui teinte
c'est vraiment comme une cloche un son
pur ce sont isabelle l'a appris au fil
des années c'est grâce à lui qu'elle
peut maintenant qualifié une belle
porcelaine et savoir comment la
travailler pour la rendre unique
c'est une passion en tant qu'objet
recherche du bel objet et puis c'est
aussi une passion en tant que quart
faire vivre de donner de donner une
deuxième vie parce que l'objet existe en
tant que lui-même même une assiette
lambda il existe en tant qu elle même
mais delà de la décorer d'essayer de la
décorer d'en donner juste la
quintessence d'en faire quelque chose de
d'essayer d'en faire quelque chose
d'exceptionnel
une passion commencé par hasard en 1989
alors salarié dans l'industrie
pharmaceutique
isabelle suit des cours de peinture sur
porcelaine comme loisir un loisir qui
deviendra son métier six ans plus tard
assiettes tasses décoration elle peint à
la main chacun de ces objets une fois
qu'on a va passer le fait le dessin
c'est bon la préparation des couleurs
l'application de la couleur soit à la
plume pour un travail très fin de
précision soit au pinceau l'objet est
ensuite mis dans un four à 8 150 degrés
pour fixer la couleur sur la porcelaine
la cuisson peut être répétée trois ou
quatre fois selon la peinture et le
motif un travail créatif de patience et
de précision
il faut aimer le support je pense que
c'est très important d'aimer le support
et il faut vraiment se rendre compte que
c'est un travail d'exigence
persévérance exigences minutie pour
pour avancer une exigence que transmet
isabelle en tant que professeur chaque
semaine à ses élèves un savoir-faire de
tradition née au 9e siècle avant
jésus-christ aujourd'hui plusieurs
formations existent pour continuer à
faire vivre cet art ancestral et demain
troisième épisode de notre série
consacrée à l'artisanat nous irons à la
rencontre d'une créatrice de bijoux à
maurepas ne manquez pas ce reportage
et avant de nous quitter un mot de ce
sport à présent une fois n'est pas
coutume nous allons parler d'aviron dans
ce journal les régates de versailles une
compétition centenaire était organisée
ce dimanche dans le parc du château de
versailles
le rendez vous a réuni plus de 1200
rameurs un reportage est signée mickey
l'ami d'euros et patrick jacques de
dixmude
c'est l'une des plus grandes
compétitions d'aviron en ile-de-france
les régates de versailles était
programmé ce dimanche sur le grand canal
du château organisée tous les deux ans
le rendez vous a attiré plus de 1200
raemerich 35 clubs et sportifs sont
venus de la région parisienne deux camps
de rouen de compiègne et même le turin
en italie
les rameurs en bleu de 12 13 ans à au
vétéran sans limite d'âge
il n'y a pas d'enjeu sur n'y a pas de
sélection sur ces courses
c'est simplement une course de début de
saison mais qui permet d'étalonner quand
même les équipes parce que les équipages
vainqueur aversa ils sont souvent sur
les podiums nationaux ensemble dans la
catégorie minimes féminines l'équipage
le simple du cercle nautique de
versailles remporter l'une des finales
en devançant de près de 3 secondes et
rameurs du perreux c'était vraiment très
intense et je pense qu'on est tous
crever et je pense qu'on a surtout mal
était notre médaille comme on est tout
fier même même pas au milieu de la
course on n'était pas sûr mais dès les
250 mètres c'était c'était gagné on
savait qu'on pouvait tenir et on y
arrivera cette finale minimes féminines
a été suivie par plus de 3000
spectateurs réunis sur les bords du
grand canal rendez vous en 2018 pour une
nouvelle édition des régates et c'est à
présent la fin de cette édition merci de
nous avoir suivis tout de suite à rester
avec nous à suivre le 7-8 société
présentée par nicolas kirillovitch
entouré de ses invités il sera question
du tourisme en ile de france
je vous souhaite une très bonne soirée
vous retrouve demain pour un nouveau
numéro du journal as bonsoir